-Elle fait partie des députés
qui n'ont pas tardé
à se faire un nom
dans la nouvelle assemblée.
Une ascension rapide
mais pas si surprenante
quand on sait que mon invitée à fait
ses armes aux côtés
d'une ancienne ministre,
aujourd'hui maire.
Générique
...
Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Vous avez pratiqué
la danse classique
avec l'espoir
de devenir danseuse étoile.
De cela, il reste une médaille
du conservatoire
de Lille, quelques photos,
et un témoignage vidéo
assez inattendu.
-La tête gonflée de projets,
elle jubile...
Musique intrigante
persuadée que ses ambitions
se réaliseront dans sa région.
Ma région donne l'impulsion
à mon ambition.
Musique dynamique
...
-Environnement.
-Aménagement.
-Financement.
-Ordre de lancement.
-Naturellement.
-Recrutement.
-Ajustements.
-"Ma région donne l'impulsion
à ma vocation."
La musique s'interrompt.
-On reconnaît bien le côté
années 90.
C'était un clip de promotion
de la région
Nord-Pas-de-Calais,
tourné quand vous aviez 17 ans.
-Oui,
l'année du bac.
-C'est drôle parce qu'au début,
dans cette vidéo,
on a l'impression
que la voix off
qu'on entend parler
parle de vos propres ambitions
politiques pour la région,
pour la ville de Lille.
-Oui, c'est incroyable.
Quand on se replonge il y a 30 ans,
car j'ai une cinquantaine d'années,
on voit cette ambition globale
de notre région
des Hauts-de-France,
de Lille capitale régionale.
Et je me retrouve depuis quelques
années à porter un projet politique.
J'imagine que c'était mon destin.
Ca me correspond.
-Vous avez pratiqué
la danse à haut niveau.
On dit souvent
que c'est un enseignement très dur
qui peut forger une personnalité
pour le reste de sa vie.
C'est votre cas ?
-Je le crois profondément.
C'est la discipline,
la rigueur et l'effort.
Ca m'a beaucoup appris aussi
pour le collectif.
La danse, ça se pratique
dans une équipe, dans une troupe.
Donc ce travail collectif, cette
harmonie qui doit être trouvée,
je le retrouve dans ma vie
professionnelle puis politique.
-Vous avez fait vos débuts
en politique
un peu par hasard.
Il y avait
un poste à pourvoir au cabinet
du maire de Lille de l'époque,
Pierre Mauroy, en 1997.
C'est à ses côtés, donc,
que vous avez débuté.
Mais c'est surtout
avec Martine Aubry
que vous avez fait
votre apprentissage.
Pendant 13 ans, vous avez été
cheffe de cabinet
puis directrice de cabinet
de la maire de Lille.
Qu'avez-vous appris à ses côtés ?
-J'ai beaucoup appris
sur la conduite de la politique
locale, pour une grande ville,
donc à la fois la construction
d'une vision et les sujets
opérationnels,
de crise.
Quand on est maire d'une ville,
on est à portée d'engueulade,
à disposition permanente
des concitoyens.
J'ai gravi les échelons
auprès de Martine Aubry
en commençant
de mon concours
d'ingénieur territorial
et en ayant occupé le poste
de directrice de cabinet
pendant son mandat jusqu'en 2014.
Moi, ça m'a appris la gestion
du quotidien
d'une grande ville
et de ses relations
avec son territoire,
son environnement.
C'est beaucoup de bons souvenirs
professionnels.
-Fin 2013, vous êtes partie
travailler à la SNCF,
mais il était prévu que vous vous
présentiez aux municipales
en tant qu'adjointe à l'Education.
Sauf qu'en janvier 2014,
coup de théâtre, vous lui dites non.
Ca surprend tout le monde.
Ca ressemble presque
à un refus d'obstacle, au moment
où elle vous a proposé de basculer
en tant que femme politique.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
-Pour moi, c'était une avancée,
une décision courageuse dans ma vie.
J'avais 40 ans, et souvent,
à 40 ans, on fait le point,
sur ce qui est important
en termes d'engagement.
Et j'avais beaucoup de sujets
qui me heurtaient
et qui progressivement,
dans la maturité
de ma compréhension
de l'ensemble des enjeux
politiques, locaux et nationaux
me posaient problème.
Des désaccords politiques
sur les rythmes éducatifs.
C'était l'époque
des relations
avec les parents
d'élèves très tendues
sur l'imposition du samedi matin.
Il y avait les sujets culturels,
bien sûr,
qui m'ont mobilisée,
et la relation
au commerce, à l'entreprenariat.
On avait une défiance du maire
de Lille de plus en plus prononcée
envers les commerçants
et artisans de la ville.
Et tous ces sujets ont fait
qu'au moment de m'engager ou pas
dans cette liste municipale,
j'ai choisi de rester à la SNCF
et de me dissocier
avec des sujets de valeurs
qui posaient problème.
-Vous avez poursuivi
votre carrière à la SNCF
comme directrice
des relations publiques.
Et en 2016, en descendant
les escaliers
dans le métro, vous êtes
gravement blessée au mollet.
Ca a été une épreuve
longue, difficile, je crois,
pendant un peu plus
d'un an et demi.
Vous étiez en fauteuil roulant
ou avec des béquilles.
C'est une épreuve
qui vous a changée ?
-C'est une épreuve qui heureusement
était temporaire.
J'ai eu un moment
où je me disais
que je ne remarcherai jamais
normalement.
Mais ça m'a fait vivre
ce que beaucoup
de personnes en situation
de handicap vivent,
dépendre des autres,
devoir organiser sa vie
différemment dans les mobilités.
-Ca a créé
de la colère en vous ?
-Oui, on se sent impuissant,
on peut pas décider soi-même.
On a besoin de ses enfants,
de son mari, pour le quotidien.
Ca renverse un peu les relations
familiales, professionnelles.
A la SNCF aussi, ça a été difficile,
même si j'avais des solidarités
des collègues
et que c'est une entreprise
accompagnante
quand on a une difficulté
de santé.
Ca m'a beaucoup appris
sur le rapport au temps,
le rapport aux gens,
et j'ai été plus attentive
aux autres.
J'essaie de conserver ça
même à la vitesse politique
à laquelle on agit aujourd'hui.
-Vous avez fini
par vous en remettre
et le 22 janvier 2018,
vous êtes apparue
au premier rang des voeux
de l'opposition municipale
à la maire de Lille,
ceux de la droite.
Vous entrez en politique
contre celle auprès de qui
vous avez grandi.
C'est une décision murie
pendant votre convalescence ?
Ca vous trottait dans la tête ?
-L'engagement politique,
il m'a titillée au moment
où Emmanuel Macron s'est engagé
et a proposé cette nouvelle offre
qui faisait confiance
à la société civile,
qui déplaçait les clivages,
et dans cet élan
des présidentielles et législatives,
j'étais convalescente,
donc j'ai lu beaucoup,
et tout ça m'a permis,
effectivement, à un moment,
avec les rencontres des Lillois
qui m'ont accompagnée, d'oser
proposer une offre politique
nouvelle,
celle de la majorité
présidentielle,
à Lille, pour les Lillois
et pour la métropole lilloise.
C'était un moment surprenant
pour certains,
mais qui était déjà bien mûr
chez moi.
-Alors avant de pouvoir
vous présenter face à Martine Aubry
aux municipales,
vous avez dû
vous imposer dans cotre camp.
Il y avait la député LREM
de l'époque, Valérie Petit,
qui voulait aussi se présenter.
Vous l'avez battu à l'investiture,
puis à nouveau
quand il a fallu briguer
l'investiture
aux législatives.
Ces deux campagnes
se sont déroulées
dans un climat très tendu.
Vous assumez
une forme de dureté
en politique ?
-Non, je dirais plutôt que je subis
une forme de dureté et de violence.
Pendant la campagne municipale,
on a vu des violences verbales,
psychologiques,
physiques.
A mon local de campagne,
des menaces de mort,
de la diffamation...
-Comment vous expliquez
autant de violence
contre vous ?
-C'est ce que beaucoup d'élus
rencontrent aujourd'hui.
On est dans un territoire
qui était très tenu
par un système.
C'est les baronnies
dans les grandes villes françaises.
Et on apporte, avec la majorité
présidentielle,
une nouvelle offre,
et tout ça, ça dérange.
Donc quand on dérange,
on doit se battre un peu...
-Il y a quand même un côté
dur, chez vous.
Se présenter...
Vous vous êtes présentée
aux municipales face
à Martine Aubrey, vous avez perdu
avec plus de 20 % au second tour.
C'est quand même dur
de se présenter
face à celle
qui vous a fait grandir,
qui vous a introduit ?
Vous comprenez
qu'elle se soit sentie trahie ?
-Je ne suis jamais présentée
pour être contre.
Je me suis présentée avec un vrai
projet collectif.
On a construit le projet
avec l'ensemble
des associations, de la société
civile, des commerçants,
des infirmiers, des profs,
des chefs d'entreprise
qui avaient envie de changer
le visage de Lille.
-Ce n'est pas tuer la mère ?
On dit "tuer le père"
en psychologie.
-C'est porter ma ville.
Je suis Lilloise
depuis toute petite.
J'y ai fait l'école,
le conservatoire.
On peut promouvoir
aujourd'hui une candidature
pour avoir un maire de Lille
qui porte une vision
de la ville et de la métropole
très ambitieuse,
avec une vraie vision municipale
et nationale pour notre ville.
-Vous faites pas de cadeaux
en politique.
Mais la politique
vous fait pas de cadeaux non plus.
Il y a eu ces incidents
aux municipales
lors de vos réunions.
Pendant la réforme des retraites,
une fois élue députée,
des manifestants se sont présentés
devant votre domicile
avec des banderoles,
des parpaings et du ciment.
-TOUT LE MONDE DETESTE
LES SPILLEBOUT
ET TOUT LE MONDE DETESTE
-Alors ces manifestants qu'on voit,
ils ont muré
la porte d'entrée de votre domicile,
et il y a ces chants :
"Tout le monde déteste
les Spillebout."
Comment vous avez vécu ce moment ?
-Je vais rectifier le chant.
On l'a réécouté avec la police :
"Tout le monde
déteste Violette Spillebout."
-Effectivement, c'est pas évident
quand on l'entend.
-C'est important pour ma famille.
C'est assez émouvant
d'entendre le chant,
plus que le mur,
c'est ça qui a tourné
sur les réseaux sociaux.
C'est ça qui a beaucoup heurté
ma famille,
qui rentre dans l'intime,
dans le jugement personnel,
alors que l'engagement politique,
c'est celui de Violette Spillebout.
-Une de vos filles
était présente dans la maison.
-Elle n'a rien demandé.
Elle avait un examen du bac
l'après-midi.
Ces actions qui se veulent
symboliques
sont en réalité une vraie
violence psychologique.
On n'est pas dans la violence
physique, là.
Ce que j'ai vécu, c'est extrêmement
fort pour ma famille,
et je crois que c'est vraiment
ce genre d'actes,
revendiqués ou non dénoncés
par des syndicats,
comme la CGT à Lille...
J'ai écrit à Sophie Binet
et elle ne m'a pas répondu,
pour dénoncer cet acte.
C'est le symbole
qu'on a dépassé une borne,
celle du domicile
et de la sphère privée des élus.
Je porte beaucoup de propositions,
avec mes collègues députés,
pour apporter des solutions
à la protection et à la sécurité
des élus de de leur famille.
-On va passer au quiz,
un moment un peu plus léger.
Il s'agit de compléter des phrases
que je vais commencer.
Le plus dur,
quand on est porte-parole...
-C'est d'être convaincu
tout le temps, partout.
-D'être convaincu
de la parole que vous devez porter ?
-Oui, parfois, on a des doutes
ou on n'est pas d'accord,
et on doit être loyal.
C'est un exercice que j'espère faire
avec beaucoup d'authenticité.
-Vous êtes porte-parole
de Renaissance
à l'Assemblée.
Pour les prochaines municipales
à Lille, je...
-Si tout va bien, je serai candidate
à la mairie de Lille.
Ce n'est pas une annonce officielle
mais c'est un projet que je porte
avec le collectif Faire
Respirer Lille autour de moi.
-Quand les gens me comparent
à Bree Van De Kamp...
Vous connaissez ?
-Oui, je connais.
-Dans "Desperate Housewives".
-C'est souvent un qualificatif
physique, donc je le prends bien,
mais elle a mauvais caractère.
-Et sa personnalité ?
-Le sujet,
c'est l'engagement politique,
pas être acteur de cinéma.
-Merci
d'être venu
dans l'émission.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...